all right this is a wild story that some
people are actually finding themselves
sort of sort of triggered by there's a
msnbc a tv analyst named malcolm nance
and he's been around for a while now
a former intelligence guy kind of a well
well known in in the space at this point
in time
he has actually joined the fight in
ukraine he is he is fighting in ukraine
at least to some extent against the
russian invasion and this is fascinating
and without becoming sort of like a
war porn
uh
uh
advocate um
this is someone putting their sort of
money or or their time at least
where their mouth is uh there's a report
from the denver gazette msnbc analyst
malcolm nance reveals he joined the
fight in ukraine
malcolm nance an author and former
military intelligence analyst
appeared for an interview monday with
msnbc host joy reid who said he was at a
secure location
nance was dressed in military garb and
holding a rifle said he joined ukraine's
foreign legion about a month ago to fend
off what he called russia's war of
extermination uh i have a little bit of
that interview let's check it out and
you will notice if you're watching
malcolm nance is wearing i i don't want
to use the wrong term i don't i guess
we'll just call it military garb and
he's holding a weapon as well joining me
now from a secure location in western
ukraine is malcolm nance executive
director of the terror asymmetrics
project he's fighting with the
international legion of territorial
defense of ukraine and malcolm um we
just watched that video um of you and
ali rusi was attempting to interview you
for us uh to get more information on
what you're doing we saw those cruise
missiles fly overhead so explain to us
um
why you are there and what you are doing
well as you know i spent quite a bit of
time here in the pre-war period and when
the invasion happened i had friends who
were in donetsk who are in the ukrainian
army who are writing to us and telling
us we're not going to survive tonight
we've been hit 500 times uh you know
these graduates at defense language
institute these were my friends and you
know as the more i saw of the war going
on the more i thought i'm done talking
all right it's time to take action here
so uh about a month ago i joined the
international uh legion here in ukraine
and i am here to help this country
fight you know what essentially is a war
of of its of extermination this is an
existential war and russia has bought it
to these people and they are mass
murdering civilians and there are people
here like me who are here to do
something about it so there's some on
the left who have reacted to this by
saying oh god the glorification of
malcolm nance
doing this
is uh war porn it's glorifying violence
it's pro-war to say what a great thing
that malcolm nance is doing
i don't see it that way nance is 61.
he could just stay with his cushy msnbc
gig and i'm guessing he does consulting
and speaking and all these different
things
he is at least theoretically i mean
listen you know if you come back and you
tell me nance isn't really exposed to
any danger this is all a setup he put on
a uniform and he's there but he's in
like the part of the country where
nothing's going on okay let me like
listen there's no evidence of that but
i'm sure someone would make that claim
but at least in theory he is he's there
and he's putting himself in at risk
and he believes that this is a war of
aggression by russia against ukraine
that ukraine is fighting a defense of
war
and along those lines if you're in a
position to have to defend your country
uh and by proxy that's what malcolm
nance is doing you're not pro-war
because you say wow he's actually in the
real world doing the thing that many of
us just sit in front of microphones and
say
this is the side that i'm on for lack of
a better term so seeing this and saying
that the other aspect to this is there's
a there's a big i don't want to call it
big there's a loud movement
on the online left
which
is very
just
black and white antagonistic
against any government or intelligence
agency and they haven't liked malcolm
nance for a long time they say this guy
is
the epitome of the sometimes they'll
even use the term deep state or of the
establishment intel that got iraq wrong
and they got this wrong and they got
that wrong and so they see this as the
sort of worst of the worst
meshing
of american intelligence
and
um corporate media uh and pro-war
democrats or whatever you want to say i
i really just don't see it that way i am
as anti-war as anybody else
this is a defensive war for ukraine and
he is at least to some degree putting
his money where his mouth is it's not a
glorification of war like a war movie i
just don't see it that way if you
disagree and you think that is what this
malcolm nance thing is then i want to
hear from you
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the united states for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think
it's happened to me i've talked about
this on the show before and it can be
really bad sometimes you get a text that
your email password has been changed
your bank calls about unusual activity
your paypal account is getting drained
and it can happen very very quickly to
keep my accounts protected i use aura
our sponsor aura is identity theft
protection
fraud monitoring and password management
all wrapped into one aura monitors the
dark web for your information they
monitor your credit card they monitor
your bank accounts
my subscription to aura gives me peace
of mind protects my devices it protects
all of my different accounts and i can
monitor everything in one place on the
app if i get attacked aura actually
takes action to prevent and resolve the
issues in real time and aura is letting
my audience try it completely free for
14 days go to aura.com
pacman the link is down below